so
Luchador from
Colombia
so now I'm doing the
strange breeding C3 again but
I've scored so many points with it,
always with the strange position,
now I've swapped things around, I'll try it
again, of
course it's not exactly the
most active right now, but it's still
interesting
later  so calmly um that's what you're going to do
now is bishop F4 or something like that,
let's have a look at it, let's make a
thumb pawn game out of it,
at least
yes you understand that,
of course I don't know how to do that either,
so the three
if I go in here now
makes eight, I think so  Meaning,
maybe you can now play F4
then you would otherwise have Stonewall but with
the bishop already activated here you
also have to go to H4, of
course you can't do that, you can basically take
King A7 then 5 King George Queen F7 yes
because the Tumi 8  has moved,
okay, I thought he was at least going
to the side somehow, which of course isn't
exactly nice, but
now let's see if he
can't
do checkmate here somehow or something like that,
so you can checkmate now somehow it's
stupid  from a
springer to F3 or springer G5
looks good,
yes, very good, yes of course friendly,
a spoon H7, well